bueno hay que recordar que desde un
principio más bien lo interpretó esta
segunda vuelta como un referéndum contra
macrón y es justamente el cariz que tuvo
su discurso y el voto que obtiene en el
territorio de ultramar en general y
también en los campos y entre los
trabajadores para ella es la muestra de
que una parte importante de los
franceses no están contentos con la
política y ellos son los que llaman 'los
olvidados' y ahora comienza esta campaña
hacia las legislativas y ella quiere ser
la voz de esos olvidados sobre todo ella
agradeció a las personas que se le
sumaron según ella en esta segunda
vuelta que no votaron por ello en
primera pero que votaron en segunda
porque justamente no están de acuerdo
con el presidente actual y ahora
presidente electo manuel macro cne de la
green lote estuvo reunido un rato con su
equipo político salió luego aquí a darse
un baño de masas literalmente provocó
graves incidentes entre los camarógrafos
hubo mucho revuelo pero quiero decirles
una cosa aquí el ambiente sigue muy alto
a la gente no se ha ido comencé hace
poco conversaba hace poco con un joven
por marine lepén que lo vi en varios
actos de los que me tocó
y él me decía no te puedo decir que
estoy contento estoy triste obviamente
pero se vienen estas legislativas
recalcando obviamente ese voto histórico
para la extrema derecha y también la
abstención histórica para poner en
contexto estos dos votos que obtuvo hoy
me ha bien lo está